AN INTERCONTINENTAL
BALLISTIC MISSILE NAMED
SATAN 2 BY NATO.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION
IS FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND
SYNDICATED COLUMNIST LEROY
MURDOCK AND AUTHOR OF DIRECT
FIRE FORMER BRIGADIER
GENERAL TONY AT A TIME THAT.
GENERAL, I'M GOING TO ASK
YOU SINCE WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THAT
ABOUT THAT --
>> Judge: ARE WE ENTERING A
NEW PHASE OF A COLD WAR?
>> I THINK WE MIGHT BE,
JUDGE.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO BACK UP
AND SAY THAT I THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP, JUST AS HE
UNLEASHED US TO DEFEAT ISIS
HAS DONE MORE TO ATTACK AND
DEFEND AGAINST RUSSIA THAN
PRESIDENT OBAMA EVER DID.
AND THEN AS WE LOOK AT THE
MISSILE THAT, YOU KNOW,
PRESIDENT PUTIN SUPPOSEDLY
SHOWED THE LAUNCH OF, THAT
IS, YOU KNOW, ATTACKING THE
CONCEPT OF MUTUAL ASSURED
DESTRUCTION AND WHAT HE
WANTS TO DO IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE FEEL UNEASY ABOUT
OUR ABILITY TO DEFEND
AGAINST THE WEAPONS THAT
RUSSIA HAS.
AND SO WE LAUNCHED OFF A
SUBMARINE AN
INTERCONTINENTAL BALLISTIC
MISSILE THIS WEEK IN THE
PACIFIC OCEAN.
SO RUSSIA.
>> Judge: YOU DON'T HEAR
ABOUT THAT AS MUCH.
>> EXACTLY.
>> Judge: SOUNDS LIKE A
TIT-FOR-TAT AGAIN.
>> VERY MUCH.
ALMOST LIKE A WAR BY PROXY
THAT WE HAD IN THE COLD WAR
AS YOU MENTIONED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SEGMENT.
THIS IS THROUGH THE
ELEMENTS, POWER DIPLOMATIC
INFORMATION.
MILITARY, ECONOMIC.
YOU SEE SPIES BEING FIRED.
YOU SEE INFORMATION WARS.
THAT'S AN INFORMATION PIECE.
>> Judge: THEY CALL IT A SPY
SPAT AS I WAS READING.
DOORY, ALL THIS TALK ABOUT
THE LEFT AND HOW THE
PRESIDENT HAS COLLUDED
AFTER, WHAT, 14, 15 MONTHS,
NOBODY HAS ONE IOTA OF
EVIDENCE.
IS THIS GOING TO HURT THE
LEFT IN TERMS OF THE MID
TERMS WITH THE PRESIDENT
BEING SO TOUGH ON RUSSIA?
AND NOT ONLY THAT, DEROY, HE
HAS 23 COUNTRIES, NATO, THEY
ARE ALL BACKING THE
PRESIDENT.
WHEN OBAMA USED TO TALK
ABOUT IT, THERE WAS NO ONE
BEHIND HIM.
NOW THERE IS.
>> WELL, THE LEFT HAS BEEN
PREACHING THIS GOSPEL FOR
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF OR
SO.
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A
PUPPET OF PUTIN AND HE DOES
WHATEVER PUTIN SAYS.
AND YET HAVE YOU SEEN AS YOU
SAID ORGANIZING THIS
DIPLOMATIC EFFORT TO REMOVE
THESE DIPLOMATS AROUND THE
WORLD JUST YESTERDAY I THINK
WAS, POLL LAND ANNOUNCED IT
WAS GOING TO PURCHASE
$5 BILLION IN ANTIMISSILE
SYSTEMS IN THE UNITED STATES
POINTED AT RUSSIA, I'M SURE
TRUMP HAS PROVIDED OFFENSIVE
WEAPONS TO UKRAINE.
A MONTH OR SO AGO AN ATTACK
ON HUNDRED MERCENARIES IN
SYRIA.
IF IS HE A PUPPET OF PUTIN
HE IS NOT A VERY WELL
BEHAVED ONE.
>> Judge: THERE WAS TALK
TODAY ABOUT TWO OF OUR
ASTRONAUTS ARE ON A
VESSEL -- ON A RUSSIAN
VESSEL THAT HAS GONE INTO I
GUESS OUTER SPACE, SOVIET SO
I I CAN'T.
IS THIS ALL TALK GIVEN THAT
YOU KNOW EVERYBODY KNOWS WE
HAVE AMERICANS ON THIS
RUSSIAN VESSEL OR WHATEVER
IT'S CALLED?
THAT'S WHAT I WAS SAYING
EARLIER JUDGE, THIS IS
INFORMATION WARFARE.
THIS IS TWO COUNTRIES
POSTURING FOR POWER IN THE
POWER VACUUM LEFT BY THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
NATIONAL SECURITY STRATEGY
TALKS VERY MUCH ABOUT PEER
COMPETITORS, CHINA AND
RUSSIA.
AS I SAID, HE HAS DONE MORE
TO COMPETE NOW BEGINS CHINA,
RUSSIA, NORTH KOREA THAN THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION AND
WE HAVE GOT A TRILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF 30 YEARS OF
MODERNIZATION OF THE NUCLEAR
WEAPON ARSENAL THAT WE HAVE
GOT, THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS LAID OUT.
SO, HE HAS TAKEN THIS
SERIOUSLY AND HE IS STANDING
UP TO RUSSIA.
>> Judge: RIGHT.
HE HAS SOME FORCE BEHIND HIS
WORDS.
YOU KNOW, DEROY, RUSSIA IS
ACTING LIKE THEY ARE THE
VICTIMS IN THIS WHOLE THING
THAT THEY DIDN'T DESERVE TO
BE BOOTED OUT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THE DEADLY
NERVE AGENT THAT WAS USED,
THAT NO ONE COULD REALLY,
YOU KNOW, GUESS PROVE YARD
THE DAUGHTER IS NOW TALKING.
SHE CAN, I IMAGINE, TELL US
HOW THE NERVE AGENT WAS
DELIVERED, WHO MAY HAVE
DELIVERED IT.
WHO THE LAST PERSON WAS THAT
SHE SAW.
THINGS AREN'T LOOKING GOOD
FOR THE RUSSIANS IF IT IS
INDEED THE RUSSIANS WHO DID
THIS.
>> I GUESS SOMEBODY RUSSIAN
MAY WANTED TO BE A CORPSE
MAY NOW BE A WITNESS.
SHE MAY BE ABLE TO SPEAK UP
AND GIVE THE EXACT KIND OF
EVIDENCE YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
IT'S FASCINATING WHERE THIS
CASE AND OTHER CASES WHERE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ASATURDAYS
SIN NATEED BY MOSCOW.
THEY DON'T JUST USE RAT
POISON.
OR PUT A PILLOW OVER
SOMEONE'S FACE.
USING THE TYPE OF AGENTS
TIED BACK TO MOSCOW ALMOST
AS IF THEY WANT TO LEAVE
THEIR FINGERPRINTS BEHIND.
MAYBE SOMETHING THEY WANT TO
DO.
SENDING A MESSAGE TO OTHERS
RATHER THAN ELIMINATING